For the past five years,
I've been working
as a psychologist in Russia,
a country where mental
health is stigmatized
and people are often afraid
to seek professional help.
Right now, people in Ukraine
are fighting for their lives.
What is happening
is devastating and traumatic,
and everyone, including both
Russians and Ukrainians,
will need mental health support,
but on different levels.
No matter where in the world
I'll be working from,
I'm committed to helping people.
Psychotherapy for me,
has and will always be
a force of understanding,
change and peace.
And now it is needed more than ever.
Unfortunately, there is a lot
of resistance to psychotherapy in Russia.
First, for historical reasons.
During the Soviet Union,
psychiatry was often used
as a political tool,
and this is just a small part
of the state attitudes toward people
that deeply traumatized the society.
Since then,
Russia has seen major reforms
in the psychiatric system,
and there are a growing number of good
specialists in the mental health industry.
Yet problems remain.
As in many countries where mental
health has been stigmatized,
proper regulations
for practicing psychologists
have never been developed in Russia.
There are no licensing procedures
or any laws protecting clients
from incompetence and fraud.
There are a lot of scammers,
people who simply took
a three-month course,
tarot card readers or astrologers
who say they're
professional psychologists.
As a result,
a lot of people don't know
how to choose a professional
who fits their profile
or are even victimized
by such unprofessional help.
In the absence of regulation
and interest by the state,
I saw an opportunity.
With my team, we created a platform
with an assessment system
for psychologists
and the means to get people connected
to the therapists they need,
therapists they can trust.
Through this assessment system,
we help people overcome the risk
of being harmed by professional help
or falling into despair,
of giving up hope
they will ever feel better.
We have based our assessment
on a hypothesis backed up with research,
saying that there are common factors
that significantly contribute
to psychotherapy effectiveness.
This includes a variety of ways
in which a therapist and the client
create a special bond
of trust and partnership.
Unfortunately, in most psychotherapy
training programs in Russia,
not much attention is paid
to those common factors.
The bottom line,
having a good diploma is not enough.
Our psychologists undergo a test
and a case study interview,
including ethics questions,
because the client's safety
is the priority.
The sad truth is that only around
15 percent of applicants
pass our selective assessment screening.
After this assessment,
it is important to match a client
with the right specialist.
With our current matching algorithm,
we've already helped
more than 35,000 people
receive safe psychotherapy.
We also offer pro-bono sessions
and free educational materials
to support those who can't afford therapy.
And I believe the number of people
in need of mental health support
will increase due to the PTSD,
chronic stress,
trauma of two years of the pandemic
and all the global events
we are experiencing.
And this is the beginning
of a bigger mental health catastrophe
we all need to face.
We're trying our best,
even though we work in a tough environment
with the strong stigma
and the cultural memory of psychiatry
as an instrument of oppression.
Our goal is to minimize the risk
of people giving up on therapy
because it's dangerous.
On an individual level,
it means a barrier for well-being,
and unfolding potential.
For the world,
it means a loss
in productivity and economy.
Just depression and anxiety disorder
cause the global economy an estimated
one trillion dollars each year
in lost productivity.
But I believe that the most
important costs
are the decrease in the quality
of connections between people.
The loss of self awareness.
An increase in hatred and violence.
Psychotherapy is not only
about one individual finding help
for their individual issues.
When one of us is wounded,
all of us share in that wound.
Psychotherapy is a way to move forward
from the burden of the past
and trauma of the present
by breaking cycles of hurt,
by embracing the path of healing
and self-knowledge.
Because by knowing ourselves and seeking
healing from our pain and trauma,
we also become better human beings
in our interconnected world,
bringing a real hope for peace.
Thank you.
(Applause)